you guys have such good chemistry in
this movie I read though that you met on
Twitter many years ago is that true
Twitter or Instagram was one of them
so whose get into hoody Emily what
happened probably and then we had this
chemistry read where she came and met me
beforehand and helped me get comfortable
with the lines and everything and it
helped me so much and then we just like
totally got along on set hey you
wouldn't want to do something sometime
would you I'm really busy during the day
but like be free at night patrick
Schwarzenegger and Bella Thorne
couple up in their new flick Midnight
Sun out Friday
Bella's character Katie Price has a
terminal illness called
XP I have a severe sensitivity to
sunlight katie gets labeled a vampire in
the movie but Bella gets candid with
Edie about the real-life name-calling
she's experienced in the spotlight I
feel like you've been labeled and
there's been so many misconceptions
about you what's been the most hurtful
and kind of set it straight for us when
people look at you and they're like off
you know dressing a certain way you have
to be covered up or else you're the
salaat of some sort
you know I'm whatever they want to call
you whatever demeaning term they think
fits you best and especially with you
know certain people's backgrounds
considering my own you know those things
are taking a little bit more to heart
you know if someone says like why do you
dress that way is it because something
that happened when you're younger and
you're like oh maybe it actually is oh
that's a good point you know it's like
it's it's kind of those small moments
where you're like oh I wish that didn't
dig as deep as it did yeah that's gotta
be hard but you always come out the
other side or so it seems
thank you earlier this year the former
Disney star revealed she was the victim
of sexual abuse as a child she credits
new boyfriend mods on for bringing out
the best in her
so I'll keep Hey ah that's what I love
about this is how Charlie is attracted
to Katie over her singing so how what
attracted you guys to your own
significant others
I think Fermanagh was definitely meeting
someone that's just so happy you know
that that's kind of his whole thing and
and for me coming from someone who's a
little bit glass half-empty
it really is nice for me to have someone
on my back that's like no it's good it's
good it's good it's good because it's
like you're always your harshest critic
so if you're dating your significant
other like those are the people that
build you up
why do you say glass people could say
pessimistic people could say realist you
know glass half-empty
instead of half-full do you feel like
your relationship has transformed you in
a way but like has made you a happier
person you know it depends on what day
you catch me on but I definitely have
changed so much of my mindset or when I
when I see me going towards the negative
I'm like Patrick has been dating model
Abbey champion for over two years in the
movie Charlie gets attracted to her not
only from the singing but kind of purity
in real life it also kind of starts like
that you know one thing maybe starts you
off on the relationship and then does it
click do you guys have the chemistry is
that something you're joining and having
fun and do they bring out the best in
you and stuff and yeah it's your
surprise this is your first movie a
leading man in romance so how did he do
and how do you feel about it I felt
great yeah it's so much fun working with
Bella and working on this project I hope
that everyone really loves it you're
gonna laugh you're gonna cry bring your
tissues and also Patrick is shirtless
and I'm shirtless
that's the best part I put it my whole
life to feel
[Music]